hey what's going on humans it's march
22nd
2021 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message and if you want a
little insight
into the inner workings of how the
reuben report team operates how we
prepare for this show my producer
michael just
turned to me 10 seconds ago and said no
nazi jokes today no f-bombs can you do
that dave
i don't know i don't know we're actually
going to find out that will be the test
of the next 30 minutes of my life we
shall see
i'll give you a little more insight into
how we do things i think i've mentioned
this once or twice the way we
select the stories and the way we figure
out what we're going to do and how we're
going to do it
is that throughout the day as i'm on
twitter unfortunately and whatever other
places i'm getting news
i just send things to my guys emails
throughout the day like oh this is a
story i'm interested in or this is an
image or a meme that i saw whatever it
is
and then in the morning michael and i go
through everything and we pick things
and
as you know i like to do only like three
or four stories because i'm not trying
to just
club you over the head and keep you
crazy and angry like everybody else
i want you to be happy and enlightened
and live your life
bananas i know uh anyway usually we go
through a list of about six or seven
stories but there was so much craziness
this weekend and i guess
it was sort of the end of last week just
kind of bled into the weekend and then
there were like a whole bunch of viral
things and biden falling and everything
else
that we had 16 stories to go through
this morning uh we have
whittled it down using our professional
professional whittling machine
we've whittled it down to three key
stories that i think will set us up for
the week
uh before i get into all that guys uh as
always click that
subscribe button and that notification
bell and then maybe
just maybe if the youtube overlords are
feeling it you're gonna see our videos
who knows
uh all right we're not doing any ads
today we're rolling straight through
people so here we go so the big story
number one or i'll tell you what the
three stories are and then we'll do them
so we're gonna cover
trump apparently launching a social
media platform
that's that's the word on the street uh
so we're gonna cover that number one
number two joe biden remember the guy
that fell the other day the guy with
dementia that we're pretending is in
charge of america
uh he's got kids in cages but we don't
call it kids in cages because he's a
nice democrat he's not orange he's not a
republican
so we're going to call it different
things but now all these pictures are
leaking
of these cages and their cages there are
kids in them so we're going to cover
that
and then the by far best governor
in the united states uh in florida you
know him ron desantis
he is banning critical race theory in
their public schools which is absolutely
phenomenal we've got some video
and he in effect is what a governor is
supposed to be he's letting people make
decisions for themselves he didn't
destroy his state
he's actually saying hey we're not going
to teach horrific
ideas in our public schools that are
counter to the founding of the united
states all sorts of stuff
so those are the three stories that
we're doing today i am focused i'm ready
to go
i'm caffeinated here watch this
let's do it uh so yeah donald trump
apparently
is getting back on the social media now
we know after the
january 6 capitol hill riot situation he
was banned from twitter he was banned
from youtube
facebook pinterest spotify they don't
want him posting pictures of apple pie
or listening to music
he was basically just annihilated
everywhere i think his official email
list had problems like just
there was a digital assassination and it
doesn't matter whether you love trump or
hate trump
it was a it was a crazy move and you
know a lot of people talk about do these
guys coordinate how do they had a big
tech
all decide to coordinate like they
obviously didn't come up with this
decision completely on their own like
within
an hour everybody boots him at one time
uh one time i talked to peter thiel
about this a couple years ago and i had
him on the show talking about what
happened to alex jones and you remember
there was a digital assassination of
alex jones way back when
and again this has nothing to do with
the person's thoughts or feelings or
any comments even on trump or alex jones
but when we watch these people get taken
out and you see who applauds it
and it's like guys do you not realize
they're not done yet
like these people that like to ban
people they never they never ban people
and they're like all right we're closing
up shop everybody let's go
we're wrapping it up you don't have to
go home but you can't stay here no they
go for more people right it's blood in
the water
and they go for more people but what
teal said to me was it's not as much
that they all coordinate as they're all
sort of cowards and then once
someone makes the first move everybody
else follows so in the case after
january 6 when trump got booted i don't
know what the order was in terms of
bannings i believe it was twitter first
but
i know you guys will correct me if i'm
mistaken but then you know the rest
twitter facebook
etc etc uh youtube everything else so
twitter
and then the rest of them go uh that
it's not really like coordination as
much as just
cowardice and people following well in
any event trump has been gone from
social media the the only way he's
getting his messaging out right now
is he releases these sort of tweet-like
very
short press releases from the office of
the former president or something like
that whatever they're calling it
and then people then tweet it which is
sort of hilarious i mean if trump really
wanted to like truly troll the entire
system he should just be in effect
tweeting all day
by just every day releasing like five or
six or or 10 or 20
press releases and then just get
everyone else to to retweet them all day
long like
what what are they going to do at that
point just ban everybody i mean maybe
that's where this is all going right
we're just going to ban
everybody but over the weekend it was
announced
at least subtly i guess not so subtly
we'll see you decide
i report you decide that he's going to
be back on social media in about two to
three months
launching his own platform we've got
some video from fox news
former president trump hasn't been on
social media in months after being
kicked off
facebook and twitter but earlier today
on media buzz trump senior adviser
jason miller says that we could see him
back online in a different way
i do think that we're going to see
president trump returning to social
media in probably about two or three
months here
with his own platform and this is
something i think will be the
the hottest ticket in social media it's
going to completely redefine the game
jason miller adds that several teams of
people have approached the former
president to build that new platform
no word just yet on exactly what this
new social media platform will look like
all right so i think it's pretty clear
why i wanted to cover this story i mean
in a way this is sort of
the biggest story of the day because so
much of our lives is dictated by what
big tech and and mainstream media allows
us to see
or not to see and the way we're
manipulated by the algorithms and
everything else
uh i should preface this all by saying
that this week you know i've been
telling you guys for a couple weeks now
that uh we've got a lot going on with
locals this is a huge week for locals
we've got a ton going on
and i promise you one week from today
which i guess will be the 29th am i
right am i right on that it will be
the 29th of march i will make a bunch of
uh announcements because i've been
teasing some stuff and we've just got a
huge week for locals that i can't just
divulge everything right now but a lot
of good stuff but the reason i start
with that is because
i know how difficult it is to start a
tech company
and i know about the never ending litany
of problems
that you have as a tech company whether
it's philosophically how you want to
deal with free speech issues
whether it's technologically how you
want to deal with
storage and servers and payment
processors and all of these things
and whatever trump is doing whoever has
approached him i have no doubt that
they're discussing all of these things i
have no doubt that i've probably talked
to some of these people right like i
spend most of my days in meetings
talking to all of the people
in the tech world and how do we solve
all these problems and decentralization
and everything else um trump will have a
couple
really unique problems just to trump
because
in effect trump the person not the
platform yet but trump the man
is not allowed on these platforms at the
moment so will apple
suddenly allow his platform as jason
miller called it he's calling it a
platform
we do not describe locals as a platform
by the way i always tell
p with locals we're building you a home
and what you do with that home is up to
you though you're going to set the rules
you're going to own everything the same
way that somebody built the house that i
live in
uh i am he's no longer responsible for
what goes on in my house so
locals just has a very different more
decentralized approach to everything so
i don't know exactly what trump's going
to do but jason miller did say the word
platform there so if he tries let's say
he creates really a fantastic system
let's say he solves 99.9 of the issues
well
can he get on the app store can he get
into the
google play store which is the android
store uh can he deal
with the fact that it's very possible
that amazon could take out his servers
is he going to buy a huge server farm
somewhere in utah or somewhere in
eastern europe
how is he going to deal with payments if
say stripe
or whatever credit card payments he
wants to use if they won't allow it
there are massive massive problems i
have no
doubt that they're working on these
problems but i think this is going to be
super interesting and i also think that
you know as someone that's
that's in the tech world now i love
competition man like
more more more more like let's just all
keep creating and then what you what you
see happens
is some of these companies will pivot
some of them will change what they're
doing
i think it's possible that one of the
things that's going to happen here is
trump jr has been posting on rumble a
lot if you guys don't know what rumble
is
it's uh i believe at least partly owned
by dan bongino who at least partly owns
part of parlor
so junior's been on there a lot that's
kind of a hint
that maybe the family is up to something
with rumble maybe maybe rumble and
parlor are going to become one thing you
know there's so many interesting things
happening right now like
i think locals have sort of led in the
community based
video and audio situation i think you've
got uh you know something like
um what's called sub stack for
just written word for journalists that
are leaving the dinosaurs of the new
york times
and everything else you know there's
places for pure audio that are
like uh like clubhouse that so there's
just like so much happening i just think
it's a fun
rich space to be in and the part that
really is interesting to me is like
okay you have a like for all of us
like the regular average people for you
guys watching this and and for me as
someone that's in the game but trying to
solve some of the problems
i just know like there's so many
philosophical legal
ethical moral you know what do you do
about okay so you decentralize
everything on your system and then what
if somebody starts putting some horrible
stuff up there like some seriously evil
illegal stuff are you then responsible
for it
are they responsible for it like there's
so many issues
um that i've actually spent so much time
discussing over the last couple years
but especially over the last few months
that'll be interesting to see what play
trump can make and then when you add the
fact
that already this guy has been booted
off for everything and it's like how
will the system react to him right so if
the system goes well
trump trump is too dangerous to be on
any of these things then why would they
let his platform
be on all these things and they can they
secure it whatever he's building
if assuming he's building it not
requiring whatever it is
it's like can he secure all the data in
a way that it's not just going to be
used to steal user data to expose people
like there's so many things
anyway i obviously think it's incredibly
interesting and we'll keep talking about
it
and i just want to be totally clear
competition i love competition i love
new ideas i love new people getting in
the game
and and let's play let's do it all right
story number two which is really what's
catching fire
uh at the moment is that some photos
have been
leaked from inside a u.s customs and
border protection
temporary overflow facility in donna
texas so we're going to show you some
images in just a second but
let's remember before we get into any of
this that
remember when when orange man that we
were just talking about with crazy hair
and everything
remember when he was pregnant
remember when he was president oh lordy
remember when he was president
um remember we were all talking about
kids in cages it was a real thing that
we were worried about there are kids in
cages
aoc was concerned about kids in cages
every mainstream media will be putting
kids in cages he's separating families
he's orange he's evil
ah hitler i said hitler damn um well
anyway
now that biden's doing it it's a little
bit different of course let's start with
a quote from
cbs before we show you the images more
than 13
000 unaccompanied migrant children are
now
in u.s custody sources told and
cbs news now we've got one quote from
fox and then we'll show you those images
more than 9 400 children and teens
entered u.s border custody in february
according to data
from u.s customs and border protection
that marks a 60 percent
rise from january so actually come back
to me for one second before we throw
those images
now you may remember remember a couple
weeks ago
i think we played a video this is
probably about six weeks ago now
we played a video where i believe it was
jen pasaki uh
basically saying to people oh don't come
yet like you'll be able to come at some
point but
don't kind of come yet which is this
constant wink to people saying just come
in essence you're saying just come right
um
so now let's let's throw you a couple
images these are images from inside the
henry cooler
uh no i'm sorry these are images from
the facility that i
uh rep that i referenced a moment ago
from representative henry cooler who's a
democrat
in texas so there you're seeing a couple
images of the amount of people we're
seeing people in those silver
i guess they're blankets they they
really look like bags i mean they look
pretty freaking
dystopian this is at the temporary
overflow facility in donna texas
which is the place in essence where they
were telling us these are kids in cages
now those
kinda look like cages can we put them up
again yeah
those are kind of cages and they're sort
of locked in there and they have weird
silver bags on them looks very
futuristic and kind of evil you know
there's a nice garbage can but a lot of
people in there i wonder how coved safe
that is
i don't see any i don't see a lot of
masks from what i can see i don't see a
ton of social distancing
very disturbing but the way the media of
course is handling this
is we're not talking about kids in cages
now it's a temporary overflow facility
it's much like the four seasons in bora
bora
it's quite lovely because the democrats
are in charge not the evil orange man
well now let's show you that photo of
aoc this was a famous photo that went
viral
this is aoc this is months ago when she
went
to the overflow facility which she was
calling kids in cages and she compared
to the holocaust and all of that stuff
and she stood out there and by the way
she's in an empty parking lot right now
she's not really seeing anything she's
seeing a building
but she covered her face and she wore
all white and it was a very
sad it was a very sad thing for her to
see she hasn't said anything about
bidens
kids in cages of course the good and
wonderful and my good friend who just
launched a new show on
daily wire she recreated it that's
candace owens
she went to a fence as well because
fences are all over the place you can
get fences almost anywhere now
the old chain link fence and candace put
on all white
she put her hands to her face and she
recreated
that very emotional moment
that aoc had there we there we go look
at these two
boy oh boy who who was more emotional
truly
anyway i play that partly because i just
wanted to give candice a little bit of a
shout out because her new show
did debut on daily wire was it last
night did a debut last night or on
friday night
um but and i'll be on it by the way i'm
going to nashville i think at the end of
the month i will be on candace's show
but i wanted to really show you that
because it's like this is another
remember
last week we talked about how or we talk
about it all the time but
pretty extensively last week about how
the media depending on who's in charge
they decide
what to cover and how they're going to
cover it so when it was trump it's kids
in cages
it's the holocaust it's it's evil it's
extermination i mean all of these you
know it's inhumane all these things now
it's
it's very hands-off i should clarify aoc
actually did criticize biden
a little bit at the end of february but
obviously not nearly as hard as trump
and don't expect that that's going to
come and don't
expect that she's going to make any of
these over-the-top comparisons or
anything like that
and and this is just another one where
it's like you it's up to you
i would say to decide how whether you
care about
these kids in cages or these migrant
facilities or what are we supposed to do
with these people i mean my feeling
personally at this point
i don't think this is uh well i can
assure you it's not racist
and it's not xenophobic or anything else
but my general feeling would be
we have major problems in the united
states at the moment we've got some
stuff to deal with right
we've got whatever's still going on with
cobit and lockdowns we've got
major economic problems we have a major
mainstream media problem we have major
political strife like we've got some
serious stuff to deal with
here first i would like to deal with
what's going on in our home
and the united states if you live here
illegally it is your home
i would like to deal with the inner
workings of our family
in that regard first like let's figure
that out and then if we want people to
come or not come then they can
but this idea that we just have to let
people in
and now they're saying maybe they're
going to ship some of them from the
border facility up to some states in the
north
like just like a series of crazy things
it's like we've got stuff to figure out
for ourselves
first that is not that is not mean
it is not xenophobic it's not racist uh
you know what it is it's it's a little
bit of jordan peterson right it's a
little bit of fix yourself and then fix
the world
but we have a whole series of people and
a media elite and an
entire democratic party that if only we
could fix everything
else uh then we can fix ourselves that's
not how it works you gotta fix yourself
first so to me these people if you come
to our border
sorry you gotta go home we can't put you
in our temporary facilities
and give you our silver blankets like no
you you gotta go home
you gotta go home now if there are
actual instances where people are being
hunted down
then you know by gangs or whatever maybe
something like that
but even on the view this morning they
had some msnbc correspondent saying how
this also has to do with climate the
climate crisis which is exacerbating the
situation so that people have to come to
america
it's like if do you get it yet do you
get it it's a load of bunk that's just
being sold on us
endlessly anyway we'll obviously keep
keep talking about that but let's move
to my favorite governor in america and
one of the top 10 americans there i said
it he's one of the top 10 americans
that we got in america in 2021 governor
ron desantis
in florida who largely kept his state
open
who did not destroy all the businesses
who let people go to work
who has the second oldest population in
the entire united states
and yet somehow their death rates were
lower and all of the stuff that i've
been talking about for months
well he's he's even one-upping me on all
of that because he is now
banning critical race theory from public
school classrooms
in florida this is this is as good as it
gets you want to see what leadership is
like
take a look florida civics curriculum
will incorporate
foundational concepts with the best
materials
and it will expressly exclude
unsanctioned narratives
like critical race theory and other
unsubstantiated theories
let me be clear there's no room uh in
our classrooms for things
like critical race theory teaching kids
to hate their country and to hate each
other
is not worth one red cent of taxpayer
money
so we will invest in actual solid true
curriculum
and we will be a leader in the
development and in implementation
of a world-class civics education
there's a leader
there's a leader right that is someone
saying
the buck stops with me i'm drawing a
line in the sand and we're not going to
teach this
bunk that is rotting out every
institution in the united states that
line there is no room for critical race
theory
teaching kids to hate this country and
hate each other which in essence
is what critical race theory is doing
you know in the last couple days we're
hearing this
this new meme of um you know stop the
hate against asian people because of the
shooting that took place last week which
by the way did the guy did kill two
white people too but i know that
mainstream media doesn't care about that
do you know who hates
asian people who doesn't want to treat
asian people
equally it's not anyone on the right i
have no i have been to conservative
fundraisers i've been to concer
i speak at conservative events
libertarian events i've been to turning
point events i
ran center events i have never ever
heard
anyone say anything remotely
anti-asian ever period like if anything
if anything would ever be brought up it
would be like oh look
look at asians succeeding succeeding in
all of the things right like
they're doing the american dream it's
pretty freaking spectacular i have never
once heard even the slightest anti-asian
sentiment
do you know where anti-asian sentiment
comes from and this is directly linked
to critical race theory of course
because of the collectivist ideas that
we're going to group people based on
these cr
these immutable characteristics the left
almost holy the woke left has become
racist against asian people the same
people saying
don't be racist against asians these are
the same people who want
quotas they want quotas at schools so we
are seeing harvard
i mean i know you guys know this but
we're seeing harvard actually
discriminate against asian people that
is coming from
the left the liberal institutions that
are doing it
we now see this is happening all over
the place new york city's best charter
schools are now
they've had a lot of asians so what's
happening because asians work very hard
and care about family and are doing the
american dream properly we've got to
punish them
so we're breaking down meritocracy we
see this happening in san francisco we
see it happening in los angeles
so and then what are we doing are we
actually by by doing that
and and what the critical race theory
people would tell you what the wakesters
would tell you is oh we're helping black
people
but it's a two-way street you can't just
help people
without hurting other people right so
you either the only thing you can do in
a fair society
is go for equality and then the best
ideas went out
the people who work the hardest usually
win out the people who are trained the
hardest who have the best families who
come
who do it all right it's the best shot
you got
that's all a society can do but the very
same people
who are saying no asian hate right now
which of course
i believe in no asian hate obviously
but the very same people who are saying
it are the ones who are
who are actually systemically putting it
into our institutions and saying
discriminate
against those asian people because
they've had it too good that is a
huge freaking problem and on top of the
fact that if you were to look
at almost all of the instances uh this
event last week notwithstanding if you
were to look at almost all of the
instances that are happening especially
in the san francisco area related to
attacks on asian people
they happen to be coming from black
people so that is not a blanket
condemnation of black people
but do you think that if you tell people
oh those asians they've got it too good
right and you've been oppressed do you
think that might turn a certain amount
of those people on the asian people
it might it might right like that's just
reality so like just try to be aware of
these
things and then you can think clearly
about what's going on here
folks i i felt good about today's show i
hope you felt good about today's show
we've got shows every day this week as
we're one to do
by the way i've got an interview coming
tomorrow which we just taped it's super
interesting lawrence fox who's an actor
he's a british very well known british
actor who a couple years ago about two
years ago
basically got cancelled for saying some
basic liberal stuff have we been through
this story before
almost got cancelled and then has
decided to fight because what i always
tell you guys i like
fighters not just people who talk but
people who fight well he started a new
political party
the reclaimed party to reclaim
liberalism
true liberalism which i would say is
basically modern conservatism but we can
argue about that separately
uh he started a new party and he is
actually running for mayor
of london um so i can't wait if you if
you don't know lawrence fox i can't wait
to introduce you to him
uh part one will be out tomorrow of
course our full interview from last week
with uh david sacks is up on youtube
and uh on my locals channel right now
and if you want to play along i posted a
lot of dog pictures a lot of food
pictures
i chatted with people this weekend we
posted nature pictures we got several
hundred people just nature
and no fighting no trolls no bots we
built something good and i look forward
to donald trump getting in the game
more is better all right guys
roomport.locals.com
make sure you subscribe right here have
a great day everybody we'll see you
tomorrow